a
en medio de la segunda ola de la
pandemia del cob y 19 más de 25 millones
de peruanos se eligen entre 18
candidatos al próximo presidente del
país y a un nuevo parlamento de 130
congresistas los últimos sondeos de
opinión posicionan a los postulantes
presidenciales más opcionados yonhy
lescano hernando de soto verónica
mendoza church forsythe keiko fujimori y
rafael lópez aliaga se prevé empate
técnico y nada asegura que candidato
pasará a la segunda vuelta porque la
diferencia entre el primero y el sexto
es de apenas cuatro o seis puntos
dependiendo de la encuestadora el
desinterés de los ciudadanos encabeza
todos los sondeos de opinión existe un
30 por ciento de electores indecisos
muchos de ellos
repudian a la clase política debido a
las denuncias de corrupción y en medio
de todo esto la organización de los
estados americanos lidera los 17
organismos que verificarán el desarrollo
de las elecciones generales este domingo
11 de abril en paralelo más de 96 mil
policías visitaran seguridad en los más
de 12.000 locales de votación
[Música]
ecuador decía en segunda vuelta quién
será su presidente para gobernar durante
los próximos cuatro años el palacio de
carondelet sede de la presidencia
recibirá desde el 24 de mayo a su
decimosegundo inquilino desde el retorno
a la democracia en 1979 en este país
desde entonces nueve presidentes se
definieron en segunda vuelta electoral
andrés araus un economista de izquierda
auspiciado por la coalición unión por la
esperanza une es corriente afín al ex
presidente rafael correa y guillermo
lazo un empresario conservador de
derecha banquero y político auspiciado
por la alianza creó partido
socialcristiano que buscará su tercer
intento para llegar a la presidencia del
país andino según las encuestas los
escenarios son inciertos unas benefician
a andrés arados con más de 10 puntos de
ventaja sobre guillermo lasso otras
anunciado un empate técnico con un
margen muy estrecho mientras que otras
encuestas dan una ventaja al candidato
guillermo lasso por cuatro puntos
porcentuales unas elecciones en medio de
un llamado el botón 1 por parte de los
movimientos indígenas que denunciaron
fraude electoral dejando por fuera a su
candidato ya cooper es el próximo
presidente deberá gobernar en medio de
una profunda crisis económica y
sanitaria a causa de la pandemia
[Música]
este domingo bolivia vivirá su tercera
elección en el marco de la pandemia de
kobe 19 se trata de la segunda vuelta
electoral en cuatro de las nueve
gobernaciones del país donde el
movimiento al socialismo es decir el
partido oficialista competirá con
candidatos opositores las gobernaciones
que están en disputas son la paz
chuquisaca tarija y pando hay que
recordar que en la primera vuelta
electoral el movimiento al socialismo es
decir el partido de evo morales y de
luís arse se hizo del control de tres de
las nueve gobernaciones mientras que la
oposición triunfó en dos entre ellas la
de santacruz que es el departamento más
próspero de bolivia les decía que
bolivia vive su tercera elección en la
pandemia pues la primera se realizó en
octubre del año pasado cuando lo izar se
fue elegido presidente del estado la
segunda fue en marzo de este año cuando
se realizó la primera vuelta de las
gobernaciones y también se celebraron
elecciones municipales y finalmente este
domingo el mas calibrará cual es su
poder en las regiones luego de haber
tomado el
gobierno central con el 55 por ciento de
los votos
[Música]